so i see that my hair's got so much
volume like what how do i do that again
like what is the trick to getting like
yeah so i mean for you honestly it's
just all about getting that little bit
extra volume let me cut your hair so you
can wash and guide but also if you want
to put a bit of bouncing away this is
going to be your best friend this is
colorado style and steroids it's a
texturizing spray it's a game changer
and making your hair big but i'm sure
it's going to give you that lived-in
feel so this is for you oh you can take
that away with you but you see how it
gives you that kind of success
my hair did not look like this before
well i didn't know my hair could even do
this and you'll be able to flip your
head around from side to side you know
okay
you know but it's got body and it's got
hold you can see
and this is kind of tips i think i could
teach the women in organization ready to
empower i think just being able to show
them different ways to feel pretty about
themselves and ready to empower a really
cool like put a couple of these tips
into some of the times we do beauty
classes for the women in the
organization so thank you for this
let's go show drew yes let's do it
[Music]